which avengers should have had a costume
all along and which avenger has the very
best costume in the entire mcu keep
watching for a look at some unpopular
opinions about marvel's movie costumes
after a quick cameo as a shield agent in
2011's thor clint barton would make his
real debut as hawkeye in the avengers
only to spend the first half of the
movie under the thrall of loki and the
mind stone in his scepter he's freed
from mind control in time to join the
other heroes in fighting off the
invasion of new york by the chitari
establishing him as a member of the
avengers going forward unfortunately he
never actually looks the slightest bit
like a superhero the classic hawkeye of
marvel comics originally wore a purple
and blue costume with a pointy wolverine
style mask the hawkeye of the movie owes
more to the version from marvel's
ultimate universe but even that
character is often depicted with a more
distinctive costume than the movie
version in the avengers clint barton
basically just wears a tactical vest
pants and combat boots sure when he's
with shield at the beginning and then
taken over by loki that outfit makes
sense but after that scene between him
and black widow on the shield
helicarrier when he's just been freed
from mind control and declares that he's
joining the fight wouldn't it have been
cool if he'd put on a new outfit to
reflect that years later the hawkeye
series would make a plot point out of
the blandness of his costume clint
barton insists that his job is done
better if he doesn't call attention to
himself kate bishop insists that he has
a branding problem how about
enough materials to make your costumes
plus two more
i know a certain someone who needs a
little help with theirs while he
shouldn't have worn buccaneer boots and
a loincloth over his pants something in
blue and purple with a mask or helmet
would have been a nice touch
the outfit scotland wears in ant-man is
based very closely on the classic
ant-man costumes worn by both lang and
hank pym in the comics however the
comics version always shows some of the
characters face in the movies scott's
face is mostly hidden which makes
ant-man look oddly alien and even creepy
which is especially strange for such a
humorous down-to-earth character while
it might be a bit more of a challenge
for the digital effects artists ant-man
would work better if he had a human face
visible in his heroic identity plus it
would be paul rudd's face which is not
only one of the most handsome faces in
movies but also one of the most
comically expressive as well
in the early days of the marvel
cinematic universe everyone seemed much
more reluctant to let superhero movies
be as colorful as comics have always
been with hawkeye and a taxable vest
black widow and black leather and even
captain america's patriotic colors
somewhat muted the palette felt oddly
limited then came avengers age of ultron
and the debut of the vision age of
ultron might be one of the least beloved
mcu movies but paul bettany's evolution
from disembodied artificial intelligence
to powerful android avenger is one of
the best things in it from the moment
the vision first appears he looks like
he stepped out of a comic book panel in
a good way with his green outfit yellow
cape and crimson face he shows that
comic style color schemes don't have to
be toned down or discarded for live
action adaptations for those viewers who
really love superheroes and their
costumes it was a huge step forward
there was a lot of great stuff in the
disney plus loki series but there were
also some missteps too the introduction
of the time variants authority was a
perfect follow-up to the
reality-breaking events of avengers end
game with alternate timelines becoming
as much a part of the mcu as they are of
the marvel comics multiverse getting to
meet sylvie and the other alternate
loki's was also a lot of fun however
that's nothing compared to what was done
to loki by the end of the season and
costuming was a big part of that due to
the events of the show loki ends up
wearing a tba uniform windbreaker dress
shirt and skinny tie that makes for an
interesting contrast with his usual
green and gold space godgar but it has
uncomfortable implications in the
context of the end of the series when
loki begins to think that he and sylvie
may be going too far and that he who
remains and the tva might be right about
the need to control the timeline this is
loki after all the god of mischief and
chaos anyone who's a fan of loki loves
him because of that mischief and chaos
so nobody wants to see him as a guy in a
brown jacket and tie arguing in favor of
law and order
watch it where's your manners
oh hey quit it
in general the costume chadwick boseman
wore as black panther is great it's also
quite close to the comic book outfit
albeit with the kind of detailing and
texture that works better in a movie
however the marvel comics version of
t'challa often but not always wears a
flowing black cape with his costume
giving him something of a batman look
for a superhero who's also a king it
makes him seem a bit more regal than
your average marvel brawler obviously
the black panther couldn't wear a cape
all the time but when he was acting in
the role of wakanda's ruler it would
have been cool to see bozeman in the
cave plus if it was part of the
high-tech costume given to t'challa by
his genius sister shuri the cape could
probably retract on command so black
panther could be ready quickly for
situations that require more freedom of
movement although there are variations
throughout the franchise the main
costume chris evans wears his captain
america is pretty much perfect it takes
his classic design and colors and adds
some realistic looking details that make
the suit look more tactical and less
costumey there's only one quibble with
the outfit and that's how often steve
takes off the helmet leaving aside the
fact that cap's not invincible and that
helmet presumably provides some cranial
protection not wearing it also makes him
feel a little less like the
star-spangled adventure he's supposed to
be going around unmasked and uninhabited
feels less like a character-based choice
and more like the filmmakers being
concerned that fans need to see chris
evans handsome face as much as possible
while it's true that mcu steve rogers
has no secret identity to protect the
comics version of the character does and
that mask with the a is still an iconic
look
after steve rogers decides in avengers
endgame to live out his life in an
alternate past with peggy carter the
government chooses a soldier named john
walker to become the new captain america
this is a story that also happened with
a few changes in the comics but a big
difference is that when walker was
captain america in the comics he wore
the exact same costume steve had worn
for the falcon in the winter soldier
they dress walker in a similar but
distinct outfit that hints at his later
identity as us agent the problem with
this is that the whole john walker story
is about this guy who isn't as capable
or stable as steve rogers tarnishing the
reputation and the very idea of captain
america the tv series does a good job of
telling that story but symbolically it
would be a lot more effective if he wore
the classic captain america costume
no character's costume in the mcu
balances all of the needs of live-action
adaptation from comics better than the
distinctive garb worn by dr strange the
blue tunic and red cloak are immediately
recognizable from the classic version of
the character but with realistic
detailing and texture in place of a big
blue trident design and leggings in
addition to his cloak of levitation
which still has a high collar but a less
ridiculous one than the comics version
he has his big amulet the eye of
agamotto from which he gets much of his
power even beyond his resemblance to the
classic steve ditko design strange looks
like a modern day wizard which is
exactly what he's meant to be
[Music]
dude you're embarrassing me from the
wizards spider-man's arrival on the
scene in captain america civil war was a
game changer for the mcu and also for
live-action depictions of spider-man
after tony stark shows up in queens to
recruit peter parker spider-man debuts
during the movie's big superhero
confrontation appearing as if from
nowhere to catch captain america's
shield out of the air dressed in a
costume made for him by stark then
something amazing happens the eyes on
spider-man's mask change size to focus
on what he's looking at spider-man is
one of the few classic superheroes whose
costume has always covered his entire
face this can create a challenge for
artists because he still needs to be
able to express emotion for as long as
he's existed the standard way of dealing
with this problem is to depict the
oversized eyes of his mask moving and
changing size as if they're realized
getting bigger for surprise narrower for
anger and so forth for obvious reasons
however nobody had attempted to depict
that in live action until the mcu the
excuse that his costume is a high-tech
star creation combined with a line or
two about how light filtration helps
spider-man focus his overactive super
senses enables his mask to be as
expressive as it's always been on the
page and that allows for a friendly
neighborhood spider-man who is far more
human and relatable when he's in costume
than any previous incarnation
spider-man's mcu costume is pretty much
perfect but his first couple of super
villains have left something to be
desired the main villain of spider-man
homecoming is the vulture but shocker is
also there as a secondary antagonist in
the vulture's employee unfortunately
neither character really wears a costume
just a mix of street wear and high-tech
gadgetry that vaguely evokes each
character's classic look it's one thing
for the vulture to have metal wings but
it's kind of a shame to put that metal
helmet with the glowing eyes on him when
just shaving michael keane's head would
really highlight his resemblance to the
marvel comics vulture the mcu vulture
and shocker are menacing but they're
just not as iconic as they ought to be
fortunately the second movie fixes that
problem as mysterio jake gyllenhaal
wears a visually striking version of the
super villain's classic bubble-headed
green costume which turns out to be just
as special effects generated as his
superpowers
in his first few cinematic appearances
thor were a version of his classic
asgardian garb from the comics black
leather armor in set with metal discs a
red cape and even a winged helmet in
some shots although the widespread fear
of letting superheroes look silly on
film keeps him from wearing the helmet
for long still with the long blonde hair
and hammer he's instantly recognizable
as the comics character on the other
hand the level of detailing on his armor
is a bit much and it misses the jack
kirby but real aesthetic it seems to be
aiming for landing somewhere in lord of
the rings knockoff territory for the
early mcu it was fine but it was never
anything to write home about then thor
ragnarok came along and all of a sudden
thor was cool stripped of his hammer and
exiled from asgard by his estranged
older sister hella thor becomes a
gladiator on the planet's car he gets a
haircut from stan lee no less and a new
outfit and it's totally a glow up no
longer is thor a cosmic prince and
ceremonial looking armor now he looks
like the badass fighter he actually is
with simpler leather armor cool war
paint and only one pauldron a look that
always works of course his appearance
continues to evolve and he'll definitely
need another makeover after sinking into
depression in avengers end game however
since his next appearance will be in
thor love and thunder which is directed
by taika with titi with costume designs
by ragnarok designer maze rubio we can
trust that he'll once again look great
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]